so they're picking up well
okay we do two different surgeries there
is one surgery at the level of the brain
we do two little craniotomy put
electrodes in order to record the brain
signal and another surgery at the level
of the spinal cord where we put
electrodes on the top of the spinal cord
at the place that is responsible for leg
movements so between these two there is
communication and electrical
communication a digital bridge that is
then reactivated the legs the most
surprising thing happened after two days
I could control my hips the brain
implant picked up what I was doing with
my hips so that was like
yeah the best outcome I think for
everyone
with the brain spine interface I can
control the stimulation by thought so I
can decide when to start and when to
stop with the stimulation
I am in
full control of what the stimulation
does
and that gives me
a lot of freedom which I didn't have
with
previous therapy